[Music]
kim jong-un
is in charge of north korea
and north korea has uh strangely claimed
that kim jong-un's dad kim jong-il
invented burritos in 2011. of course he
did it's a legacy movie yeah
oh burrito burrito it's a korean word
even mexicans say burritos aren't real
mexican food and so it came from
somewhere oh really mexicans say
burritos on burritos these aren't true
like you're not gonna find a burrito in
mexico okay you find it here but not in
mexico the mexicans you could have just
claimed it but now somebody's taking it
yeah the guy from north korea wait
burritos there's nothing more american
that's what they say
when you go to like taco bell taco bowl
okay wrong one yeah yeah they don't do
burritos they don't like when you go to
guadalajara everything is like it's like
a whole spread and you like you make
your own taco type of deal i say hey can
i get a burrito and they go we don't do
that i'm like
i'm in
on you what do you think is mexico
north korea
like well actually funny funny you asked
he never had a burrito when i was in
mexico same i've only had bitter tacos
yeah but you know what i did have was a
[ __ ] queso dip oh damn that [ __ ] was
so good dude do you think that it's a
dick
queso
oh case of dick
case of dick
she's the queso dip that [ __ ] was so
good
the [ __ ] stringy stringy cheese man
you go
i go i go there i'm like uh this is good
but do you have any velveeta
i'm like not as surprised at the kim
jong il burrito thing as i am about
learning that burritos aren't from
mexico that's what they all say they go
it's not it's not
so the north koreans were kind enough to
bless the mexican people with burritos
in 2011. i read that it was like a wheat
rap
like it's not even like a yeah that's
that's their name yeah
according to google like comrade raps or
some [ __ ] like what do they call it you
just type in burrito origin it says
mexico [ __ ] i'm googling why are they
abandoning it all the time they keep
abandoning it it's a capitalist
conspiracy check another website just
you know make sure that we're really
doing our research what's the original
we need communist google
because you know google is [ __ ] a
western capitalist you know like
algorithms [ __ ] up yeah
we need we need we need we need cougars
i just
origin it's mexico as well gorditas
all right chalupas yeah what about
chalupa what about wheat wraps
crunchwrap supreme a wheat wrap because
that's what they call it in north korea
that's just like a sandwich wrapper put
a wrapper a plate of chalupas mexico
there you go wow
google is like give it up you know what
the other thing though
i'm gonna have to say i think i've eaten
a burrito before 2011. you have i have
when uh yeah taco bell i should say taco
oh is 2011 the year that kim jong-il
invented it yeah it is i think if they
were gonna say that they should have
said he invented a long time before that
just in case i used to eat burritos uh
from albert tacos and this is so good
yeah that's like 19.99
but also in in north korea
the burrito's probably a new invention
because they probably don't get that
much food right yeah that's true so it's
like he's like i blessed you guys with
this [ __ ] wheat wrap because they
invented the hamburger too charlie
trying to say it's a case of parallel
thinking
that at the same time you just have like
the mandela effect almost yeah
hey dude the tortilla came from mandela
that's so america mesoamerica before
2011 in in north korea they probably
don't even know what the [ __ ] is they
don't even got [ __ ] wheat yeah to
even make the burrito with a wheat wrap
damn that's very true huh yeah well they
have some farms obviously but yeah it's
it's so the the this claim follows an
equally badly propaganda story that
alleges that he invented a dish called
doubled
bread double bread with meat which was
very similar to a hamburger it sounds
like a sandwich double bread with me
okay hold on hold on dude how do you
have the [ __ ] brain to invent
something so good as the hamburger and
not invent a good name for it double
bread and meat double bread double bread
with meat
sounds cool and korean like maybe it's
the kim jong-un
kim jong-un man i like that's true he
wasn't good at branding
do you think maybe it's because
since not a lot of people have food
there
when you actually take really really
basic things and put it together that is
a new invention over there yeah it is a
new they never had that's just the way
patent works out there right they can't
even leave their country so they can't
dispute aren't they all like
malnourished because they're starving
all the time no my question is is do
they have all-you-can-eat korean
barbecue north korea hell no and i don't
even think they call it korean over
there i actually don't think that
they're that malnourished because
according to state tv news footage north
koreans can be seen devouring burritos
at a stand outside of devouring burritos
outside of a food factory in pyongyang
okay so they make them sound like games
is that propaganda though no it's from
state tv no it can't be or if it's
official news but where do they put in
their burritos what's what's in a normal
look like carrots and cabbage it's a
wheat tortilla and it looks like a
vegetable
but they are they're cooking the meat
like in the rotating uh vertical you
know like kebabs yeah yeah
yeah yeah we'll have that thing right so
he invented that [ __ ] does that mean
they have that record maybe it's easy
for him to invent like the double bread
meat thing because like most people have
only had like one bread so they couldn't
ever like they were doing two meats in a
bread and there was one
it was like an open sandwich those are
north koreans they're not very hungry
are they see nick they're happy dude
yeah they look pretty full i thought he
uh banned people from wearing those
coats no no no leather it's leather ones
that's that's leather trench coats yeah
you know i think what we do here is is
laugh and say ha ha ha ha ha you you
didn't invent that but then i'm actually
very jealous and envious i think that's
what the root of our humor is because i
wish i had millions of people to lie to
and be like hey guys i invented the
coffee and oh my god you're [ __ ]
genius dude you do have none of these
people go ahead and just speak to them
no but they wouldn't believe me they
think i'm ridiculous
this is kim jong-un inventing salt water
taffy
holy [ __ ] that thing is huge i don't
know what that is but it looks like a
giant piece of butterscotch candy that i
really want to lick up it's warthers
originals you know you know what that's
my favorite that's where the the factory
is north korea this says i'm gonna eat
this and this one goes i can't have none
i can't have it
that's so true though and at least i get
to watch it get made damn that guy looks
so happy at candy or or he's just like
this better tastes good otherwise i'm
dead yeah he's nervous yeah he's
tripping right he's [ __ ] sweating
balls this guy's like man i eat ten
thousand calories a day but i i sure
burned it off
i can't believe we're the same age man
and he has a whole country he has
millions of people he could say whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to and they just
believe location location location
disagreement is against the law right so
i guess they won't believe me if i said
i invented a hamburger they have google
to [ __ ] check that's why you got to
give it a different name like double
bread meat double red meat's pretty good
so then here's here's the propaganda for
um backing up the story see that looks
like it's painted
but they're like the fact that they
didn't have photos it was so oily that's
him inventing the burrito it's a
painting of a historical event of him
inventing the burrito in 2011 do they
have one of him inventing the arch
deluxe
or any other like mcdonald's burger yeah
i want him to come out and be like the
chalupa
you know he's like i made the mcrib
what's okay what's the next what's the
next food item he's gonna uh put his
stamp on cheesecake eater msg just a
grilled cheese sandwich potato chips
that's probably on brands
double bread and dairy a blt with with
no bacon i think they're smart what
they're gonna do is slowly introduce
western inventions to korea
north korea and say they did it right
because they can't the north koreans
can't leave and they're not going to be
like no you didn't that's that oh that
says [ __ ] from germany they can't fan
check in say they invented everything
technological too like the internet they
made apple computers did you guys hear
about the south korean who recently
defected in north korea yeah no it was a
north korean that came to south korea
then he went right back oh is that what
happened yeah you re-defected it
re-defected why did he read effect there
actually a lot of people do that
couldn't [ __ ] make it because it's
hard probably they say like
a huge percentage it could even be like
50 50 of like defectors lifestyle change
they go back well because they feel
isolated in south korea and i guess they
they feel like they're not part of the
culture in the society and they get
treated that way apparently it's
probably they have a lot to catch up on
too
like as far as life is harder for them
she's like shawshank when he finally
gets out yeah there's so much more [ __ ]
you have to worry about and you're like
yo i wasn't ready for this wow
well didn't he have a different he had
like a different job when he was in
north korea like a good job and then
came to south korea he was a janitor and
he was like [ __ ] this yeah i'm gonna go
back to being a jail president it's just
your environment right you're so used to
one way of life do they do they say how
long they defected for
is it like a year or i heard the most
most most of it is uh uh because of
family like most people that leave even
cults and all these things yeah if most
of their family members or whatever's
there like they just miss them but if
you leave isn't it popularized that if
you leave they'll hurt your family put
your family in concentration camps or
something like that then when you go
back do they just kill you they probably
welcome you with open arms comrade
welcome back there's something that's
funny is they're trying to say like dude
that guy was just a [ __ ] spy
but then they're like no he wasn't
because i guess he was a gymnast in
north korea went to the south it became
a janitor and then it's [ __ ] really
hard to sneak either way yeah so they're
like guys it's a [ __ ] spy but he's a
gymnast so he did the splits he jumped
the wall so he's he flipped and he died
jumped the wall yeah do you really he
jumped the wall and then they they were
watching on thermal like they and they
just [ __ ] lost them because like on
thermal you don't know which the [ __ ]
guy it is
and then they lost him and then he
[ __ ] snuck all the way back and it's
too [ __ ] hard for that to not be a
spy come on wow like you went both
directly people say that too like uh kim
jong-il
or
sends spies so then they can give
disinformation and to be like north
korea's so strong man but i [ __ ] hate
them they don't feed us whatever they go
but they're so strong don't [ __ ] with
them because they're military but like
yeah i hate north korea so then like
there's just disinformation and you want
to believe them because they're talking
all the [ __ ] and they had they hit all
the like bullet points of like why north
korea sucks but then they still
emphasize watch out their military is so
strong i just find something really
weird as like this guy
defected back they haven't [ __ ] found
him there's no update from north korea
on how this guy is doing yet they're
already publishing the story that it's
defection they haven't even [ __ ]
figured it out oh yeah so you think
north korea is like getting off to it
yeah so why are they like so soon
diagnosing this as a oh no he's not a
spy i just defected back like people
defect here too
maybe that's just more beneficial as the
face of propaganda to be like look if
you're wanting a defect but then you
realize how shitty everything else is
that you want to come back it is it's
like i would rather use that story to
let everybody else know it's like hey
honestly if you want to leave now i'm
going to kill your family but you're not
even going to like it yeah there's a
story of a u.s army guy that defected to
the north
and then they use them for propaganda
it's like he's like a senior now with
like silver teeth all of his teeth are
silver yeah he has a korean wife and
then his only job was to being like
the white defector because it's so much
better on our end like captain north
korea basically damn and it's a white
guy dude
so he was like in movies and all this
stuff oh he's a hero captain north
america holy [ __ ] i mean africans in the
movies or the last north korean
the last north korean damn sorry tom
cruise captain north america no i mean
africa wanted to think of captain
america being divided as like well i
mean what about south america yeah so
south american eastern captain canada
dude captain canada goes down in one
punch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you